Tucker Carlson gets knocked by Media
Matters Democrats reom brace socialism
and the 2020 Democratic candidates race
to the far left I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
well we have a lot to get to today and
we'll jump right into it but we begin
first by reminding you that when you
enter the bathroom to make yourself
presentable for the day you need the
best products available and that's why I
love Dollar Shave Club
I love the Dollar Shave Club has
everything I need to look feel and smell
my best what I love even more is the
fact I never have to go to a store
that's because number one yes he
delivers everything I need directly to
my door number two they keep me fully
stocked on what I use so I don't run out
here's how it works
Dollar Shave Club has everything you
need to get ready no matter what you are
getting ready for they have you covered
head to toe for your hair your skin your
face you name it they've got it and they
have this new program where they
automatically keep you stocked up on the
products you use you determine what you
want when you want it it shows up right
at your door from once a month to once
every six months that's what I do for
there amber lavender body cleanser it is
so calming and soothing and I'm a guy
who can use some calm and smooth soothe
so go check out their products age well
black leather black pepper shampoo
they've got just the best product plus
but they're handsome discount the more
you buy the more you save and right now
they've got a bunch of starter sets you
can try for just five bucks like their
oral care kit after that the restock box
ships regular size product at regular
price so what are you waiting for get
your starter set for just 5 bucks right
now at dollarshaveclub.com slash Ben
that is dollarshaveclub.com slash pen
once more dollarshaveclub.com slash pen
all right well we begin with a Media
Matters doing what Media Matters does
being terrible people who spend all of
their time digging up old comments by
people they don't like now the way the
media covers all of these media matters
stories is they cover it as though
suddenly audio was unearthed as the old
material suddenly rose up out of the
soil like a volcanic eruption and
suddenly the material was made public so
what you will see today is headlines
about Tucker Carlson of Fox News in
which the media report that old audio
emerges when it's a USA TODAY's headline
is Tucker Carlson refuses to apologize
amid uproar over past comments on
extremely primitive women and then
you've gotten a headline from cnn.com
Tucker Carlson refuses to apologize for
his misogynistic remarks and then you've
got MarketWatch Tucker Carlson
unapologetic after using c-word hurling
other insults at women in interview he
shrugs off as naughty hey all of this
just randomly occurred you know it's
it's magical it
spontaneous and the outrage is very real
okay it's not it's not ginned up in any
way it is very real it's a bunch of
people who are walking around and
suddenly old audio for my 2007 just boom
clocked him right in the head
and they were super offended and now
they've decided to hashtag boycott
Tucker Carlson hey so let me go back to
the beginning here's what media matters
is Media Matters was a Clinton
associated institution founded by David
Brock who's one of the slimy as people
in the history of modern American
politics and it was specifically
designed to take right wing hosts off
the air Media Matters was specifically
designed as an organization that was
going to target right-wing hosts the
members of the quote-unquote vast
right-wing conspiracy and then destroy
them and the way they were going to do
this is they were going to dig up
comments or find comments that they
could either take out of context or that
they could spin up to two levels of Rage
unforseen by human eyes before and then
they were going to call up advertiser so
they're gonna militarize a small base of
people to call up advertisers on
right-wing shows and then convince those
advertisers to pull their advertiser
advertising lest there be blowback and
boycotts so they did this to Rush
Limbaugh remember they did this to Rush
Limbaugh in the aftermath of his
Casandra flock comments you'll remember
that they've tried to do this to Sean
Hannity they've tried to do this to
Laura Ingraham they've tried to do this
to pretty much everybody on the right
Media Matters makes a living going after
the advertisers of everybody else named
this huge endowment from a variety of
left-wing sources including George Soros
so they have a huge amount of money and
this means they can dedicate employees
full time to simply going back and
taking up everything that people who are
conservative have ever said and then
trying to use those things to Club them
over the head it's all bad faith it's
all gross and the specific goal I mean
that they're not shy about this the
specific goal is to knock people they
disagree with off the air now this is
actually a very easy business it really
is I know because a few years back I ran
an organization called truth revolts
truth revolt was specifically an openly
designed as a right-wing version of
Media Matters we said so openly it was
in aspect to the david horowitz freedom
center and what Ruth revolt was designed
to do was create mutually assured
destruction so for example what we would
do is every night we would watch al
Sharpton show and every night we would
watch Martin Bashir's show and every
night we would watch Alec Baldwin's show
every Friday night and then
would call up advertisers we would have
a hundred people that's all it took
we'd have a hundred people and we would
issue emails to those activists and we
would tell those activists call these
advertisers and tell them to stop
advertising on Martin Bashir when Martin
Bashir says that somebody should should
excrete into Sarah Palin's mouth and
then the advertisers would drop because
the advertisers are notoriously
squirrely when it comes to political
when it comes to political advertising
they don't want the blowback mostly
advertisers want to be left alone
mostly what advertisers want is they
want to be able to advertise to their
audiences in peace they advertise on a
wide variety of shows every advertiser
on my show for example advertises on
left-wing shows as well and that's good
for the country it is good for the
country that advertisers advertise on a
wide variety of political shows but
Media Matters wants to make it
unpalatable for advertisers to advertise
on any show that is not on MSNBC which
is why they are now taking up audio that
was publicly available when Tucker
Carlson was working for wait for it
MSNBC and now they're using it to try to
start boycotts against wait for it Fox
News that's what Media Matters does you
have to understand this agenda before
you can understand why all of this
outrage is ginned up why all of this is
fake why an enormous amount of this
outrage is simply created out of whole
cloth by the left-wing in order to
target Tucker Carlson there is not one
person hashtagging boycott Tucker
Carlson today who's a regular watcher of
Tucker Carlson show not one there's
nobody going after Tucker Carlson today
who is a Tucker Carlson fan and now is
just shocked at the stuff he said to
Bubba the Love Sponge between 2006 and
2011 because that's what all of this is
the columnist a researcher at Media
Matters who has the worst job in America
Madelyn pelt
she says she spent a hundred hours
listening to Tucker's old episodes with
Bubba the Love Sponge shock-jock radio
program between 2006 and 2011 now you
may be asking was any of that old audio
offensive at the time that people really
care at the time and the answer was no
Bubba the Love Sponge is actually a
pretty popular radio show and it was
certainly popular back when Tucker was
on it and no one seemed to have any real
problem with the stuff Tucker was saying
because they understood it this is a
shock jock radio program where the
entire purpose of the show is to shock
people Bubba the Love Sponge was
basically a a softer version slightly of
Howard Stern
so this is the same thing as when the
media tried to dig up old appearances of
Donald Trump on Howard Stern and then
use that to bash Donald Trump as though
appearing on Howard Stern is what people
really think or as though appearing on
Bubba the Love Sponge is Tucker's most
thought-out political commentary so
Media Matters spends hundreds of hours
hundreds of man-hours digging through
the archives to try and find stuff that
they can go after Tucker for and
honestly this is how the internet works
now I experienced it pretty much every
day myself
where folks on the Left will go back
into my Twitter archive and try to find
something take it out of context find a
bad old tweet that I don't agree with
anymore and then bring it up ten years
later and then say ah well you know
you're a bad guy because you tweeted
this ten years ago you know what I don't
have a time machine you know what you do
have on the Internet is a wayback
machine
okay the wayback machine allows you to
see pretty much anything anyone has ever
said and what that means is that you're
probably gonna find some stuff you don't
like but here's the deal there is a
statute of limitations when it comes to
political opinions if you have moved
forward from those opinions or if you
are asked about those opinions and you
say yeah I don't believe that anymore
that's fair because you know what you're
not you can't do realistically speaking
go back in time you can't
Tucker can't go back in time to 2007 and
say to Tucker in 2007 I'm Bob love on
Bubba the Love Sponge you know Tucker
yes Tucker you know what Tucker I think
it's a bad idea to say that all right
Tucker I agree that's not something we
can do in real life here's what you can
do in real life
ask Tucker about those comments you can
say you know Tucker you said this back
in 2007 is that something with which you
agree and then you might get a good
faith response from Tucker Carlson you
can always tell the folks who are bad
faith in politics by their refusal to
hear any response to their own old stuff
if you go to somebody and you say like
Bernie Sanders for example you said him
you know back in the 1980s you defended
Cuba what's your take on that then you
have to listen to his answer maybe he
says he was ignorant maybe he says that
he disagrees with what he said then
whatever it is the reason that old audio
of Bernie Sanders is still useful is
because Bernie still believes all the
things that he believes back in the
1980s the same thing I am sure is not
true of the stuff that Tucker Carlson
said on public loves money hey listen
this is not about me defending Tucker
per se I defended James Gunn James Gunn
was a director you'll remember him from
guardians of the galaxy and Jay
this gun had some bad old tweets some
bad old tweets and maybe in which he
made pedophilia jokes and those were
taken out of context in bad faith to try
and suggest that James Gunn was actually
Pro Petofi Leah or was a pedophile
himself because he was making pedophilia
jokes because just like Tucker he was a
shock jock back then and he was doing
shock jockey things right Tucker was on
with the shock jock James Gunn was sort
of a shock film maker and that's what he
did and I said at the time this is old
stuff everybody knew about it at the
time that's not what he does now why are
we doing this why do we have to
manufacture outrage there are enough
things to be outraged over in modern
American life you don't actually have to
go back 15 years to the stuff that
people said back on Twitter and then get
angry about it and we see this in its
most extreme form with a couple of weeks
ago people going after the old comments
from 1971 of John Wayne and getting
outraged over crap that John Wayne said
John Wayne's been dead for 50 years and
people are still getting angry at the
stuff he's saying why because it
connects with a political agenda which
is to polarize us in the here and now
so here is what Media Matters found so
they went back and they found some stuff
that the Tucker said on Bubba the Love
Sponge in which he diminished the
actions of Warren Jeffs who was then on
the FBI's ten most wanted fugitives list
for involving arranged illegal marriages
between adults and underage girls he
talked about sex and young girls and he
defended statutory rape now some of this
I'm sure was him just being shocky
because he was on with Bubba the Love
Sponge and all of it was public at the
time it wasn't like he was saying this
behind closed doors and suddenly it
emerged Bob of the love sponge was
widely listened to nobody seemed to have
a problem with it then because he was on
MSNBC now does that mean his comments
aren't unobjectionable know if he
actually believes that this stuff is
egregious but the question is do you
actually think that Tucker believes this
stuff now do you think the Tucker
actually believed that stuff then or was
he just appearing on a shock jock radio
show and saying shock jock things
because he was on with a shock jock a
media matters knows better than this
obviously this is all bad faith garbage
and everybody knows it's bad faith
garbage so Tucker has now responded to
all of this he put out a little
statement we'll get to that in just one
second first let's talk about your
morning coffee so I will I will tell you
yesterday the clock skipped forward and
I woke up in the morning and I was dead
and that's why I need
my morning coffee from black rifle
coffee morning coffee is an American
institution that's right when it comes
to starting my day I reach for the most
American coffee on the market black
rifle coffee black rifle coffee gives a
portion of their sales to veterans and
first responder causes black rifle
coffee is roasted or Durr guaranteeing
you fresh delicious coffee with every
order black rifles Coffee Club makes
things easy you just pick your blend in
the amount you want and black rifle
ships your coffee right to your door
every month hassle free and while
liberals threaten to further tax our
hard-earned money with their socialistic
agenda black rifle coffee is fueling the
fight for freedom by upping their offer
to 20 percent off take advantage by
visiting black rifle coffee calm / Ben
received twenty percent off your entire
order that is black rifle coffee calm /
Ben for 20% off black rifle coffee calm
/ Ben and when you use that /ban you get
20% off your entire order again the
folks of black rifle coffee wonderful
pro-american people they give a portion
of their sales to veterans and first
responder causes and their coffees
terrific go to black rifle coffee calm /
Ben check it out and get 20% off your
entire order already so Tucker has fired
back at Media Matters and he did so in
what is the most appropriate way he
tweeted out this statement Media Matters
caught me saying something naughty on a
radio show more than a decade ago rather
than Express the usual ritual contrition
how about this I'm on television every
weeknight live for an hour if you want
to know what I think you can watch
anyone who disagrees with my views is
welcome to come on and explain why
that's refreshing
good for Tucker honestly good for Tucker
because here's the way this usually
works Media Matters targets somebody
over a statement that is objectionable
but not career-ending or they dig up a
piece of all the audio that nobody cared
about 20 years ago but now we're all
supposed to care about now and then the
person is hit with a wave of advertisers
or boycotts and then they express
contrition for their comments and then
the contrition is used as an excuse to
pummel them further because it's an
admission of guilt and then the person
apologizes further and they just sort of
hope it goes away
this is Media Matters MO this is what
media matters do this is their favorite
thing to do and they and their allies
will do this based on comments that
forget about objectionable like Tucker's
comments from 2007 they'll do it based
on the unobjectionable content they
tried to do this to me early this year
when I made some comments about why
pro-life people would not be in favor of
abortion across the board even if you
knew that a person was going to commit
crimes in the future
and it made a reference to pro-life
people not killing Hitler in the womb
because the idea was that pro-life
people don't believe that you should be
able to kill people based on the
possibility of them committing future
crimes that was specifically directed at
an argument in the book for economics
folks on the Left took it out of context
and then they tried to call our
advertisers and manufacture outrage this
is what folks on the Left - so good for
Tucker Carlson for not playing that game
good for Tucker Carlson for saying
listen I'm not gonna pretend that my
contrition is going to somehow alleviate
you're crazy it's not going to if you
want to ask me about it today come ask
me about it today but if you're going to
dig up old stuff that I said ten years
ago and then use it as an excuse to just
try and destroy me as a human being try
to destroy my livelihood you can go to
hell honestly good for Tucker because
this is what the response should be from
everyone you know the response should be
from everyone when somebody digs up a
piece of ten year old audio honestly the
response should be was it public if it
was then the response should be am I
supposed to be deeply disturbed by it
now maybe I'll go ask this person about
that audio and then if the person
doubles down on a bat about a piece of
bad audio if the person doubles down
suggests that they were right about it
then that's an that's a here and now
problem so I'll explain in just a second
what this means for people who are not
Tucker Carlson like for example joy Reid
over at MSNBC so joy we host over at
MSNBC and joy Reid has a long history of
bad blog posts they're a bunch of
homophobic blog posts and anti-semitic
blog posts apparently back from 2004
2003 going back 15 years ago and people
were taking those up and using them
against joy Reid and my initial take on
joy Reid was exactly the same as it was
on Tucker Carlson which is she shouldn't
be fired
she shouldn't lose advertisers if you're
going to lose advertisers you should
Lube it lose advertisers based on stuff
you say now not stuff that you said back
in history because nobody has a time
machine we all the wayback machine we
can all see what people said ten years
ago but none of us can go back and
correct the things we said ten years ago
if we're given the opportunity to do so
now and we don't that's a different
story and that's where joy Reid went
wrong so draw Reid was asked about all
that stuff and instead of heard you
saying listen I've grown I've progressed
I don't believe those things anymore I
wish I'd never written them which is the
honest way to go about a conversation
with any human being if she had done
that that's fine right this is the way
that we all deal with stuff that we've
done in our past that we
like when we have a fight with our
spouse forget our spouse we have a fight
with a friend or an acquaintance and we
say you know I really didn't like what
you did to me a year ago in the process
you know what you're right I'm sorry
that's the end of the story is it not
now it's difference if the person says
you know what I'm glad I did what I did
a year ago I'm glad I smacked you in the
head a year ago good for me that's a sin
in the here and now that's not a sin in
the past you can't correct sins in the
past all you can do is Express atonement
for them or say that you've changed and
changed her mind that's all you can do
if you double down on that that's a sin
in the Hara now that's where joy reid
went wrong because what joy Reid did is
she said that wasn't me
I was hacked I never made a mistake I've
never made a mistake now again I've
talked about this in a variety of
contexts this idea that we have now
created a society where it is impossible
to apologize for stuff that you've done
in the past where something arises from
the past we talked about this in the
context of Kevin Hart during the Oscars
so you tweeted something ten years ago
you did a comedy routine ten years ago
and people now bring this back up to try
and wreck you and if you apologize they
say AHA that's because you were guilty
which means you were bad and because you
were bad we're gonna try and wreck you
or alternatively you say you know I've
changed say well you don't get to change
sorry if you would really if you didn't
like that stuff you said you should have
preemptively come out and you should
have apologized for it preemptively
that's the take of a lot of folks on the
Left what that means is the only people
you're going to get in politics or
public life are people who are a
unrepentant or be willing to
preemptively every time they they change
their mind preemptively come out and say
something about it and unburden
themselves we talked about this in the
context of Ralph Northam in Virginia I
said about even Ralph Northam a Democrat
in Virginia with whom I heartily
disagree on a variety of issues
including infanticide I said about Ralph
Northam that if Ralph Northam had come
out about his facebook in 1980 his
yearbook in 1985 the one where there was
a guy in blackface and a guy in a KKK
outfit and said that was ignorant and
terrible of me it shouldn't been on my
Facebook page I feel terrible about it
the reason I've not commented on it
until now is because I feel guilty about
it I wish people had forgotten now that
it's raised again it's opened old wounds
that I that honestly I wish had been
buried I that's not been my life that
would have been a
good response to the situation instead
he said that it wasn't his it had
somehow sneaked into his yearbook he
gave the same answer as joy read well
that is a sin in the here and now that's
not a sin ten years ago or 20 years ago
or 30 years ago anymore that's a sin in
the here and now well here's the way
these things should know honestly
somebody brings up an old thing you said
you either say I agree with it or I
disagree with it and then you say you
know what deal
deal if you're a fella if you're that
offended by crap I did 15 years ago take
a hike and if I say it now then you have
a right to be offended but none of this
20 years later I'm gonna go back and dig
up something that you did and then get
super offended by it now that's that's
generally absurd because once more there
are no time machines you don't get to
wreck somebody based on stuff they said
20 years ago without even asking them
whether they agree with it now or
looking at whether they were joking or
whether they were on a shock jock show
or any of the rest of it because let's
be real you're not actually outraged by
this stuff the number of people who are
actually outraged by Tucker Carlson's
bad comments from 2007 is no one
everybody on the left and again that
doesn't mean the comments were
outrageous I think if I had heard these
comments in 2007 maybe I would have been
outraged I didn't know about them but
I'm not gonna pretend to be outraged by
something that Tucker Carlson said on
Bubba the Love Sponge in 2007 sorry I
have better things to do with my life
now if Tucker comes out today and starts
defending Warren Jeffries if Tucker
comes out today and starts talking about
how much he's in favor of 27 year olds
in arranged marriages with 16 year olds
which is allegedly what he said well
it's what he said on tape with Warren
Jeffs or whatever about Warren Jeffs on
the on Bubba the Love Sponge if he says
that today then there's a reason to rip
him up and down but there's no reason to
rip him up and down based on old audio
that he has not even given a chance to
talk about or defend or disassociate
himself from this stuff the reason this
is dangerous is because it can be done
with pretty much anybody anybody who's
been in public life for more than the
last 30 seconds is going to have stuff
on their record nobody likes and if we
make it the rule you can't advertise on
any show where somebody has ever said
anything you dislike ever there will be
no more political ad there will be no
more advertising on political radio or
political television it will
circumscribe the capacity of people to
bring their political opinions to the
fore will be polarizing the public for
no apparent reason
listen if you don't like Tucker you
already don't like Tucker how many
people additionally don't like Tucker
today because the stuff that Tucker said
15 years ago or 10 years ago or whatever
it is the answer is zero everybody
already had an opinion all that faux
outrages is faux and this is faux
outrage from Media Matters and they do
it professionally because their real
goal here is not to make America better
by cleansing it of its past sins that is
not the goal here the goal here is to
throw Tucker Carlson off the air if they
don't like Tucker Carlson they should
watch a show tonight and if he says
something they disagree with then they
should then they should argue with him
but I will also say holding advertisers
responsible for the 10-year old sins of
hosts he's really gross you think that
that joy reads advertisers approve of
everything joy read said in 2003 they
weren't advertising with her then and by
the way they're gonna boycott anybody
for Tucker's old comments boycott MSNBC
they were hiring Tucker at the time he
was working for MSNBC when he said this
stuff not for Fox News all right
meanwhile the Democrats are full-scale
embracing socials mean they're enjoying
their rides on the Left we'll talk about
that in just a second first let's talk
about Congress I've had it with them
you've had it with them we've all had it
with Congress frankly I've also had it
with the executive branch I'll be honest
with you I've had it with the vast
majority of the federal government at
this point because they've completely
overrun the boundaries that were drawn
for them in the Constitution of the
United States those beautiful checks and
balances they were created by the
founding fathers to limit the power of
the federal government they've been
completely overthrown and that's why one
of the ways that we can fight back is to
use a convention of states I'm a big
believer in calling a convention of
states where we the people can propose
amendments amendments like for example
reestablishing the checks and balances
between Congress and the presidency
getting rid of executive branch agencies
ensuring that legislation passed by
Congress is understandable and on a
single issue No More omnibus packages
there's lots of stuff we could do with
some constitutional amendments calling a
convention of states however is the only
way to make that happen
there are already 3.8 million people
with us on this there are more every day
so join me and my friend Mark McClure go
to convention of states dot-com slash
been and sign the petition today that is
convention of states calm slash Ben go
check it out
right now the limitations of the
Constitution have been overthrown
there's a reason to reestablish them go
to convention of states calm slash Ben
to sign the petition today and volunteer
and help out it's a great way to help
restore the founding philosophy of the
country by reom bracing the Constitution
all right speaking of people who have
not embraced the Constitution the left
has decided to full-scale embrace
socialism which is deeply exciting
Bernie Sanders is correct he is he is in
my opinion the clear frontrunner for the
Democratic nomination at this point I
know Joe Biden hasn't jumped in but I
think that the best day of Joe Biden's
campaign will be the first day Bernie
Sanders is making overt outreach plays
toward the intersectional base I've been
saying for a while the Democratic Party
is really splintered along one line
intersectionality versus socialism now
they don't necessarily have to be in
conflict and this is where bernie is
going what he is trying to do is say
that socialism ought to be applied first
for people of minority status he
believes that socialism overall is a
solution for everyone of every race
equally but bernie is now beginning to
make sort of overtures toward the
intersectional base he's trying to jump
into the America's a racist sexist
bigoted homophobic place as opposed to
America just hates poor people which was
his his old line so Bernie is coming out
and he's saying listen my radical ideas
have now been embraced by the base of
the party and this of course is exactly
right that we talked about here in Iowa
four years ago that seemed so radical at
that time well today virtually all of
those ideas are supported by a majority
of the American people
and they are ideas that Democratic
candidates from school board to
presidential candidates are running on
today okay so yeah he is right about
this the fact is that because we live in
a time where people are disconnected
from the actual impacts of socialism
very few people in the United States
have ever lived under socialism and all
of them are expatriates from socialist
dictatorships essentially it's very easy
to re embrace bad ideas because nobody
ever sees the price tag one of the
beautiful things about being Bernie
Sanders in being a socialist in general
in the United States is you get to point
to programs in other countries and say
we ought to do that and then when people
ask how do you pay for that you go it'll
pay for itself which is the same thing
you hear in timeshare presentations and
it is not true and when whenever
somebody says you know what forget about
the price tag it's gonna pay for itself
check your wallet because I'm sure it is
gone and somebody is already buying
stolen VCRs from the back of a truck
with it yeah that is the way socialism
tends to work well it's not just Bernie
Sanders embracing the stuff it is the
mayor of New York so Bill DeBlasio
tweeted out over the weekend brothers
and sisters there is plenty of money in
this country there's plenty of money in
this world it's just in the wrong hands
yes I would like all the money to be in
the hands of a man who has never done
anything for his entire life Bill de
Blasio I also love the brothers and
sisters come Rawdon comrades if we just
we are this far from an omelet all we
have to do is break a few eggs gotta get
rid of the kulaks they have all the
money once we take the money it'll be
all better by the way worth noting New
York City is bankrupt so that's sad so
his own City is essentially bankrupt at
this point and he's got nothing to say
about that except that he wants to take
more money from rich people which of
course is not going to work okay the
reason even New Jersey even New York
Governor Andrew Cuomo has says we can't
we can't raise taxes on the rich people
anymore in this state they're all
leaving and going to Florida the largest
contingent of New Yorkers outside of New
York is now living in Florida because
everyone is leaving including by the way
Alexandra Ocasio Cortez's mom who said
she moved down to Florida because there
was less property tax
but Bill DeBlasio still trying to play
this class warfare game where he is
pushing for taking away wealth from some
and giving the wealth to others
socialism is all fun and games until
it's actually implemented when it is
implemented like in Venezuela there's no
electricity Caracas Venezuela is now in
its fourth day of complete darkness
refrigeration has failed people are
eating spoiled and rotten food
socialism working wherever it's tried
and tonka bean Norway and Denmark guys
those are capitalist countries with some
redistributionist programs stacked on
top if you're talking about socialism we
have to talk like Bill DeBlasio which
means nationalization of industry and
removal of money from those who make
business to those who don't well one of
the lead proponents of this nonsense is
of course Alexandre occasi Cortez who
says the same dumbest stuff as Bernie
Sanders but his younger and more
attractive and snaps her fingers in his
eform ation and so that means she's cool
I guess I don't know what that means in
any case aoc says if you do not have a
job she's speaking at South by Southwest
and she said if you don't have a job you
are left to die under capitalism that's
what socialism means not leaving people
to die which is weird since socialism
killed over a hundred million people in
the last century and is killing a bunch
of people in Venezuela right this
instant
but apparently under aoc if you don't
have a job under capitalism you're left
to die we should not be haunted by the
specter of being automated out of work
right we should be excited by that but
the reason we're not excited by head is
because we live in a society where if
you don't have a job you are left to die
and that is at its core a problem oh
that's a problem oh yeah you're right
you the first person ever to discover
that leaving people to die is bad which
is weird since again socialism routinely
leads people to die so long as those
people get in the way of the grand
socialist vision mass exterminations
under socialism have not been rare it
turns out dissidents are still in jail
in Cuba people in Venezuela as I
mentioned starving to death
China eradicated some 40 million of its
own citizens the Soviet Union routinely
gulag political opponents and also
killed a bunch of people in the Ukraine
in the 1930s so socialism
has been a party the notion that
socialism is just wonderful for human
lives that they are seeking to preserve
every human life and then if you don't
have a job you're left to die under
capitalism it's just absurd first of all
capitalism has been responsible for more
people rising from extreme poverty than
any force in the history of humanity
look at world GDP since the
implementation of free markets and what
you will see is a straight line up its
exponential growth in world GDP since
the implementation of free markets when
it came to top-down control of
government top-down control of markets
via government you don't even have to go
back to the socialist past to see how
much that has failed
that was the rule not the exception in
virtually all human societies up till
about 1800 and then we started thinking
hey wait what if we left individuals to
pursue their own economic decisions in
peace and world GDP exploded it is also
amazing to me and and truly astonishing
how folks on the Left so often conflate
government action with kindness man I
don't know much IOC gives in charity I
do know that people who tend to vote
socialist give less charity than people
who tend to vote Republican because
Republicans tend to be religious and
that means that we spend a lot of our
money on charity you give tens of
thousands of dollars I mean literally
per person in many cases to charity if
you just look at the studies people in
red states give more charity than people
in blue states people who are religious
give more charity than people who are
non-religious people who vote Republican
give more charity than people who vote
Democrat these are just well-established
facts the conflation of government
action with helping the poor is truly
perverse the fact is that over the long
span of history including in modern
history the first place that religious
people go when it comes to hard times is
their religious community under
capitalist capitalism does not bar you
from being part of a social institution
that helps pick up the slack government
grabbing all the resources and getting
rid of the profit incentive which is
what aoc wants to do she doesn't just
want to redistribute the gains she wants
to get rid of the profit incentive
entirely as well see that generates
enormous poverty that's not about
helping the poor it's about dragging
everybody through the mud including the
entire economy we'll get to that in just
one second first let's talk about hiring
at your business so you don't want to
hire people who don't know what the
talking about like AOC you want to hire
people who actually know how to do a job
that is why you ought to be using zip
recruiter hiring used to be hard
multiple job sites stacks of resumes a
confusing review process but today hiren
can be easy and you only have to go to
one place to get it done zip recruiter
comm slash daily wires zipper cooter
sends your job to over 100 of the web's
leading job boards but they don't stop
there with their powerful matching
technology zip recruiter scans thousands
of resumes to find people with the right
experience and then invites them to
apply to your job as applications come
in zip recruiter analyzes each one and
they spot like the top candidates so you
never miss a great match zip recruiter
is so effective that 80% of employers
who post on zip recruiter get a quality
candidate through the site within the
very first day right now my listeners
can try zip recruiter for free at this
exclusive web address zip recruiter comm
slash daily wire that is zip recruiter
comm slash daily wired Dai ly WI re zip
recruiter comm slash daily wire zip
recruiter is indeed the smartest way to
hire there's a reason that 80% of
employers posting on zip recruiter get a
quality candidate through the site
within the very first day all right
we're gonna get to the rest of a OTS
embrace of socialism and then we'll get
to some twenty twenty Democrats who are
making trouble for themselves they've
actually got some trouble get to all of
that in just a second first you're gonna
have to go check out daily wire comm and
subscribe for $9.99 a month you get the
rest of the of the ben shapiro show you
get that you get two additional hours
per day of the ben shapiro show we do to
our radio show in the afternoon and you
get you get to be part of that you get
to ask us questions during the breaks
all sorts of goodies available to you
plus you get andrew Clavin show you get
Michael modal's terrible showing all
sorts of great things plus Michael
Mosley's show when you subscribe n 499
dollars a year you also get this the
very greatest and beverage vessels check
out that leftist chairs how to recalled
tumbler it is magnificent
now I want to remind you in just eight
days my new book the right side of
history detailing the crisis of purpose
that's happening right now in Western
civilization is released so if you want
to know how we got here how we can get
back on track if you want to know what
Western civilization is all about
pre-order today at Amazon Barnes & Noble
any major bookseller I really can't wait
to share it with you yeah I think it's a
really important piece of work I think
it's the most important thing I've ever
written so I would love for you to check
it out I really do think that it's it's
a great resource particularly if you are
interested in the route
of our civilization go check out you go
check out the right side of history
today quick note there are some people
who are bringing up an old tweet in
which I say that the right side of
history is a stupid phrase yes it is a
stupid phrase when it is used to justify
whatever your politics of the moment are
right now when you are Barack Obama and
you say that if you believe in
traditional marriage you're not on the
right side of history
that's a nonsensical silly phrase
history does not have intent the whole
title of the book is a play on the
phrase the whole title of the book is if
there is a right side of history it's
that the right the right things
throughout history have been generated
by certain fundamental truths it's about
looking at what in history is good it is
not about trying to justify your silly
social proposal of the day by appealing
to in a hundred years history will have
justified me and just a quick note on
that anyway
go check out the book the book is
totally worthwhile I think it's really
good endorsed by lots of wonderful
people ranging from Daniel Hannan over
at the eu-parliament to Jordan Peterson
to Arthur Brooks I mean just a wonderful
plethora of people have endorsed it and
I'm truly grateful for that go check out
the right side of history right now
comes out in 8 days I do to the audio
reader so if you love the sound of this
voice you can get like six and a half
more hours of it yeah I read fast go
check out the right side of history
today alright I also check us out at
YouTube iTunes leave us a review we
always appreciate we are the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
so AOC so fresh so phase she is a good
representative of the fact that so many
Democrats have now embraced socialism
whole-scale and her description of
socialism versus capitalism is always
telling whenever you hear people as I
say say I would love this thing and the
cost irrelevant it will pay for itself
that's garbage and also when people say
are you a socialist and people say if by
socialism
you mean unicorns in a meadow filled
with gumdrops and you're like no that's
not what I meant I'm at nationalization
of Industry abolition of the profit
motive and generalized poverty when they
say if by socialism you mean and then
say a lot of good things they don't know
what socialism is aoc doesn't actually
know what socialism is because she's
lived in a capitalist country her whole
life I mean it's it's so funny to me
that she talks about people who lack
privilege in American society
she went to Boston University she got a
degree in econ and learned zero things
and then she bar attended and at 29 she
went straight to Congress does that
sound like a life where you lack
privilege where things are real rough
for you how do you think things would
have gone for her if she'd been living
in Cuba or Venezuela or China or Vietnam
do she think things would have been lots
better for her you know in socialist
countries anyway
AOC says capitalism is irredeemable this
is maybe the most pathetic stupid
ignorant statement of I don't know at
least the last 48 hours because
stupidity is running real high these
days
here's aoc calling capitalism
irredeemable you know the system that
has raised one that has raised virtually
everyone on the globe from abject
poverty that system according to her
there's been an 80% decline in the
world's worst poverty since 1980 but
according to a OC capitalism is
irredeemable capitalism isn't to me is
it's an ideology of capital
it puts capital the most important thing
is the concentration of capital and it
means that we seek and prioritize profit
and the accumulation of money above all
else and we seek it at any human and
environmental cost that is what that
means and to me that ideology is not
sustainable and cannot be redeemed ok
that is enough what is she even talking
about
that is not what capitalism suggests
capitalism does not suggest that profit
by destroying other people is okay
that's not what free markets are you
don't get to violate the rights of other
people for example you know it's not
capitalism me and my friends voting to
steal your money kill you and then use
your money from what we want according
to a OSC's description of capitalism
that fits right in right I'm maximizing
my own personal profit at cost to you
that's not what capitalism is free
markets are about the idea that you as
an individual have innate value given to
you by God that I as an individual have
an eight value and that in recognition
of each other's innate value we own our
own labor and creativity and that we can
trade our labor to one another for
additional benefit to ourselves and that
we have a right to accrue profit based
on our voluntary exchanges with other
people that's what capitalism and free
markets are when you mischaracterize
capitalism is socialism it's real easy
to fall in love with socialism it's
truly incredible and then it's hilarious
she describes what she thinks capitalism
is and everything that she describes is
actually an aspect of corporatism of a
perversion of free markets so she says
you know it's real bad about capitalism
is that corporations have taken over our
government just as there's all this
fear-mongering that government is going
to take over every corporation and
government is going to take over every
business or every form of production we
should be scared right now because
corporations have taken over our
government
okay corporations have taken over our
government it's so bad okay so her
proposal is that corporations should not
take over government I agree okay
corporations should not take over
government you know that's an aspect of
corporatism top-down government control
when the government has too much power
corporations try to grasp at the
government's power you know what also is
not a solution government taking over
corporations in both cases you are
talking about small groups of people who
are now controlling the entire system on
behalf of themselves but she doesn't see
this because once again it is easy to be
a socialist when you never actually have
to imbibe the cost when the cost has
nothing to do with the actual proposals
that you are making and now ALCS
foolishness doesn't stop there and the
reason we spend so much time on this is
because aoc really is in the same way
the Donald Trump is the it'd of sort of
populist nationalism he says whatever
comes to mind
AOC is the it'd of the socialist push in
the United States and that eed has about
as much brains as my two-year-old son
sticking his finger repeatedly into the
light socket and then declaring himself
a light bulb and this is this is really
dumb stuff okay so let's continue
AOC is talking here about how real
capitalism is about corporate
exploitation that is not what capitalism
is about and then she suggests you know
what solve all of us if we taxed
corporation and ninety percent so people
can sit around writing poetry now this
is something that I remember Nancy
Pelosi suggested a while back she was
talking about why health care should not
be connected to having a job and she
said that we wouldn't want people to
have job lock we wouldn't allow people
to be locked into jobs you know where
they have to provide services and goods
to others at a price instead what we
want is people who are able to fulfill
their deepest aspirations like finger
painting or writing poetry here is aoc
saying the same thing let's tax
corporations in 90% so people can write
poetry one thing she doesn't seem to
understand who's going to work for the
corporation if the corporation makes no
profit thereby providing the pay for
people to do useless crap like write
poetry that she reads Bill Gates has
talked about taxing robots at 90%
and what that means what he's really
talking about is taxing corporations at
90% and we should be excited about
automation because what it what it could
potentially mean is more time educating
ourselves more time creating art more
time investing and investigating in the
sciences more time focused on invention
more time going to space more time
enjoying the world that we live in I'm
sorry what that sorry we can stop what
is she talking about
what is she even more time going to
space on what on what more time doing
scientific inventions right because what
we need is that's the unemployed are
typically where all the best inventions
come from that's that's usually where it
happens right you just quit your job and
then you go in the back room and you
tinker around like you're on Wonderlab
from the 1990s on Nickelodeon with Bill
and lie or something and then you that's
when you come up with the greatest
inventions greatest inventions are not
made by people you know employed by
universities or or who are working for
some sort of R&D department the greatest
inventions are made by unemployed people
in their basements historically like dr.
Frankenstein for example unemployed guy
in his basement made an awesome you know
person out of different body parts
unemployed what if that guy had had to
work would he have ever made inanimate
monster no he would not have and then
would the world have been worse off you
bet you bet and what is she going
through space wait what does she think
people go home and they just build a
rocket in their backyard you think Elon
Musk just goes home and builds a rocket
in his backyard or does it take billions
of dollars to build those programs huh I
mean legitimately the insane ignorant of
this human being being touted as a
genius and she says oh let's tax
corporations at 90% okay if we tax
corporations at 90% of their profit
margin you think they're going to
maintain the same employment base do you
really think they're not just gonna fire
people or do you think that maybe they
will organize in a different way without
filing as an LLC for example they'll
just file as an individual and then you
will get conglomerations of individuals
who I'll just divvy up the money as it
comes in to avoid the legal
ramifications of filing as a corporation
oh the level of stupid finally she
finishes up with her real proposal the
real proposal of the socialist is that
America is no good very bad terra
alexander's horrible no good very bad
day that is that is a o'seas
characterization of the united states
america is garbage she actually says
this America is garbage this this
beneficiary of the greatest freest most
democratic system ever created by human
minds this human being is suggesting
that America is garbage as she sits
there having been useless virtually her
entire life now being championed it
South by Southwest she was more useful
in shoes bartending Alicia's providing a
good or service somebody wanted now
she's providing a good or service nobody
wants at taxpayer expense I think all of
these things sound radical compared to
where we are but where we are is not a
good thing and this idea of like 10%
better from garbage it shouldn't be what
we settle for it's like this like it
feels like moderate is not a stance it's
just an attitude toward life of like a
dream big guys dream big America's
garbage
we have full employment by economic
statistics but America's garbage she's
sitting there at a conference for losers
and getting paid for it presumably or
her campaign is and she's sitting there
in presumably a nice a nice set of
clothing which is great everybody should
have nice clothing in a nice chair with
a microphone making Instagram photo
making Instagram videos with hers with
her instant pot that she got on Amazon a
capitalist corporation after taking uber
a capitalist corporation using sweet
potatoes provided by a capitalist
corporation on a camera provided by a
capitalist corporation to people who are
consuming it from their homes which they
paid for with money earned from a
capitalist corporation but America's
garbage guys America's garbage now
what's hilarious about this is you have
to have not visited or learn or read a
book or duck
you know sheltered you have to believe
it have to be to believe that America's
garbage truly sheltered you know
privileged you have to be to believe
that America in 2019 is garbage
you're the most privileged person in the
history of humanity be living in this
time in this place if people were
dropped into America 2019 from 1800 they
would literally think they had died and
gone to heaven
as of 1901 in every
ten babies died in infancy as of 1850
the average life expectancy in Europe
was thirty six point two years the
average life expectancy and she's
talking about America's garbage our
average life expectancy is over 80 no
one is dying of starvation obesity is
more of an epidemic among the poor in
the United States than starvation it is
and it ain't close we have more of a
problem of our of our poor people dying
of heart attacks from being overweight
than I'm dying from starvation yet
America is garbage the the utter
ingratitude of this perspective is truly
astonishing and the mischaracterization
of free markets and the attempt to paint
socialism as some sort of boon for
humanity's good side as opposed to a
collective simply trumping the
individual which is the root of
socialism the root of socialism is that
individuals don't have power over their
labor that individuals don't have power
over their creativity that the only way
for us to to ensure that human powers of
flourishing can break free is by
collectivizing everything and then
redistributing it so that some of us can
finger paint while others of us have a
gun pointed to our head at the behest of
the federal government if that sounds
great to you then by all means join the
socialist revolution of AOC and and
Bernie Sanders my goodness alrighty time
for some stuff I like and then some
stuff that I hate so the things that I
like so I was convinced by producer
Austin that I should watch the Umbrella
Academy with my wife over the weekend I
was also convinced by my wife so we were
trying to browse for something to watch
over the weekend and my wife said this
kind of looks fun why don't we try this
and I said well you know it's got Ellen
Page I don't think she's much of an
actress plus I don't like her as a
person since she thinks Mike Pence is
responsible for fake hate crimes and I
was like you know what don't be silly
just because you don't like an actresses
political speech doesn't mean that you
shouldn't watch her show and I thought
you know what good for my wife this is
correct this is correct so we watched
the Umbrella Academy and it's great by
the way the best thing in it is the guy
who plays Diego I can't remember his
name he was also in a movie that I
recommended last week with jean-claude
Van Damme he's a terrific actor actually
the show is called the Umbrella Academy
on Netflix it's a lot of fun and it's
it's really good despite Ellen page's
inability to act
in October 1989 43 women around the
world gave birth none of these women had
been pregnant when the day first began
how much do you want for it
I have adopted six children
gifted with abilities far beyond the
ordinary I give you the Umbrella Academy
does anyone wish to speak it was a
monster
okay so the show is actually pretty good
and it's pretty entertaining
the actor I'm talking that is David
Castaneda he's terrific it's that I
can't member the name of the kid actor
also there's a there's one who plays a
kid and he's really good so the show is
fun it's kind of a riff on superhero
genre stuff and and I've been enjoying
it we're about three episodes in and
it's definitely enjoyable so go check
out the Umbrella Academy if you are a
Netflix person okay other things that I
like so Alyssa Milano speaking of
actresses with silly political opinions
she tweeted out I'm trans I'm a person
of color I'm an immigrant I'm a lesbian
I'm a gay man I'm the disabled I'm
everything and so are you Kirk she was
talking to a guy who asked if she was
trans so why didn't she care about the
issue don't be afraid of what you don't
know or understand no one wants to hurt
you we are all just looking for our
happily ever after now it's hilarious
about this is this was sort of the woke
position like 35 seconds ago 35 seconds
ago it was I'm all of these people we're
all the same man you know you're trans
and I'm not trans but we're all the same
our inner humanity means that we're all
the same Alyssa Milano got eaten alive
by the left or the sweet she got ripped
up and down by the left saying you're
not any of those things you're not a
lesbian you're not a person of color
yeah I mean you are a person of color
you're not an immigrant you're not trans
you're not gay you're not disabled
you're not any of them you can't even
understand those experiences how dare
you suggested that at a root why is a
level of common humanity when the left
eats left it's one of my favorite things
in the world this sort of this sort of
marianne williamson
Sarah McLaughlin you know emo were all
the same underneath stuff that was the
hot liberalism of 2005 is now not woken
up and so Alyssa Milano got destroyed
for that tweet in which she was trying
to suggest our common humanity rails
okay time for a quick thing that I hate
so ill Hanauma you'll recall is the
awful Anne siese met a congressperson
from Minnesota who has spent the last
six weeks eight weeks in Congress saying
openly anti-semitic things and then
quasi apologizing and then being
defended by her Democratic colleagues
well over the weekend she said that she
was in fact a victim once more she was a
victim I have people every single day on
Fox News and everywhere posting that I
am a threat to this country I know what
it means to be someone who is a faith
that is fill áfive I know what it means
to be of someone who is of ethnicity
that is Phillipi I know what it means
for people to just see me as a black
person and to treat me as less than a
human okay so this is her shtick her
shtick is not that people are angry at
her because she's a vicious anti-semite
the reason that people were angry at her
is because she is a black woman she's
from Somalia and because she's Muslim
now this is sure nonsense
when Ilhan omar came to congress she
wanted to wear hijab in congress and i
had to change the rules in Congress
because you're not supposed to wear head
coverings in Congress and I actively
applauded Ilhan Omar being able to wear
a hijab in Congress as a person who
wears a funny hat daily I see no problem
with anybody else wearing a hat for
religious reasons or a head covering for
religious reasons I think that is
totally and utterly fine I think it is
quite good that we have Muslims in
Congress I mean I don't really care as
long as you hold the right principles
the problem with el hanout Mara is she
doesn't hold any of the right principles
she believes a lot of terrible things
okay so with all that said what she says
is terrible and what the right does then
what the right and the right criticizing
her is correct the worst thing would be
if somebody would come out and say that
for example
Ilhan Omar shouldn't be in Congress
because she's Muslim and because she
wears that head covering like that would
be super dumb and would play directly
into Ilhan Omar's misdirected sense of
victimhood huge Jeanine Pirro from
Saturday she's not getting this
anti-israel sentiment doctrine from the
Democrat Party so if it's not rooted in
the party where is she getting it from
think about it Omar wears a hijab which
according to the Quran 33 : 59 tells
women to cover so they won't get
molested his/her adherence to this
Islamic doctrine indicative of her
adherence to Sharia law which in itself
is antithetical to the United States
Constitution Oh No
so Ginny Imperial that's terrible crap
even Fox News came out and said we
didn't approve that monologue which is
always a bad sign it's that's so gross
and silly and stupid and backwards no
wearing a hijab does not mean that you
believe all sorts of evil terrible
things and this is this the the actual
charge that that Omar leveled at Jews
that Jews were suffering from dual
loyalty to Israel is now being leveled
at Omar in that particular clip with
Jeanine Pirro basically saying you wear
a hijab therefore you have dual loyalty
to your Islamic principles and not to
American principles by the way this is
the same charge of dual loyalty that was
originally leveled to Catholics in the
United States people saying you're loyal
to Roman to the Pope instead of to the
United States it's sure nonsense
you have to show the actual conflict
between the principal and American
principles you can't just point to
somebody's funny hat and then say well
that because of that person's funny hat
they don't believe in America if
somebody did that about my yarmulke it
would be anti-semitism if somebody
doesn't about Ilhan Omar's hijab
that's Islamophobia it's silly it's it's
not just silly it's it's nasty and wrong
so Jeanine Pirro is already quasi
apologized for it as well she should I
will recognize here but virtually
everyone online I saw zero defenders
pretty much zero defenders of Jeanine
Pirro over this comment whereas the
entire Democratic Party infrastructure
came forward to defend Ilhan Omar over
being a rabid anti-semite
so is that all ready we'll be back here
a little bit later today with two
additional hours this is why you should
subscribe because then you get two more
hours of the show later today and every
day in the meantime go pick up my book
the right side of history which was
coming out in eight days go pre-order it
right now and make sure that you get the
audio version too if you just want to
listen to it you can pre-order that too
we will be if you don't want to listen
to the show later you don't subscribe
your loss but we'll be back here
tomorrow i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
[Music]
this is the Ben Shapiro show executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey our supervising producer is
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stephens edited by Adam sy
events audio is mixed by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Joshua alvera
production assistant Nick Sheehan the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19